so I'm going to talk about analyzing
block Sean Plott inconsistency actually
well the talk will be a lot about
Nakamoto it it actually covers broadly
in protocols and I will give a few
examples as well at the end this is
joint work with PhD student Luciana
Kiefer and RB in fact the slides are
largely thanks to Lulu I have made some
edits to it more surely all the mistakes
would be on those edits so this is based
on work that appeared in CCS 2018 ok so
I will start with some basics just to
set the stage everybody is familiar with
this I'm sure but just to set the stage
and some of the notation we will use
down the road ok so a block chain is
nothing but the naive sent in its naive
sense it's a chain of blocks what is the
block a block has some transactions or
anything else you want to store inside
the block
there's a hash and which allows it to
connect and then there is this notion
which I'll mostly focus on could let us
talk about proof of work which enables
you to verify the correctness of the
block you have a chain of these blocks
and the agents that are involved in this
process are connected by some underlying
peer-to-peer network and we will give
some some assumptions about the model of
this of this network and there is the
the blockchain protocol specifies
something called the mining rule which
tells you how to add blocks to this
chain
now a block chain by itself as we are
maintaining these doesn't necessarily
have to be a chain a literal chain it
could be organized for example as a tree
the blocks that are being developed
could be organized as the form of a tree
and not just a tree you could imagine
blocks being organized in the form of a
dag where new blocks point to older
blocks and you try to derive a block
chain from this so in a general sense
you could view this as a dag of blocks
and we will try to think about this view
too at the end of the talk as we try to
analyze the consistency of these various
kinds of protocols okay so what I'm
going to talk about is analyzing
consistency of blocking protocols and in
the context of yesterday's wonderful
keynotes consistently here is referring
only to the safety properties the term
consistency there are different
definitions of it we will we will focus
on one definition it's also sometimes I
put as a common prefix property there
are other properties that you're
interested in chain quality and chain
growth change both referring to liveness
and there is a host of work in this area
including fairly recent work and one of
which you'll hear about from and so
that's there's a lot of formal framework
analyzing protocols there is a host of
dag based blockchain models and I'm just
mentioned a few of these and there are
more coming that I'm sure I've missed
their studies about specific attacks on
consistency chain quality and growth and
again there is a lot of work in this and
what I'm focusing on mostly is proof of
work protocols there is a host of
studies and proof of stake protocols
with consistency properties and what I'm
going to talk about is a very sort of a
framework for analyzing some of these
models and some of while the ideas are
drawn from various past work including
persimmon and shallot and
and I notice some of these ideas are
also implicit in other pieces of work
okay so what's the model underlying this
I'm going to put a little bit of
notation and highlight which notation is
important so at a very abstract level we
could view a blockchain as a pair of
algorithms this first algorithm is the
most important thing for us to remember
this is basically describing the mining
rule by okay the term K here represents
the security parameter that defines your
what level of security you want there is
an underlying predicate that defines the
semantics of the underlying blockchain
so this is the mining rule that we will
mostly focus on and this tells you what
a node wants to do once given a secret
given a block chip given a blockchain
that in its view it outputs the sequence
of messages that it sees in this
blockchain so we will mostly not be
concerned about this our concern is
about the first which is the mining role
there is an underlying execution
environment in which this the agents are
operating the environment initializes
players either honest or corrupt and
provides inputs to all parties okay
that's the underlying environment so you
have a whole bunch of players there are
at any point of time the players are
divided into two categories honest and
adversarial so there are a bunch of
honest parties the honest part is
execute the protocol faithfully and
that's the PI then there are adversarial
parties who are under control of of an
adversary who can do whatever they want
it's the correct part is the control by
there is the and I describe this
peer-to-peer network that is connecting
all these players here there is an
underlying think of this as a router or
a network that is connecting them we
just under the control of the adversary
so in a given round the environment
supplies some messages to each of the
players which they are going to add to
the the box in blocks then the adversary
at this point decides which players
should it make us corrupt which players
should it make us and which of the
players is corrupt so the adversary has
the full potential it can inspect the
state of every single player every
single honest plate of course it knows
the state of the players and decide to
corrupt one or more of them so there is
an underlying limit on how many players
that the adversary can corrupt and here
we will generally adopt the assumption
that even even though we're not going to
go into details about this bo Gondar of
the assumption that the the diffraction
of players that the adversary collapses
is less than half so now this is a round
is is the unit of time in which the the
basic unit of time on which other things
are being measured okay so we are going
to in Abaddon within around a new
message can be given to a to a player
player can mine a block in a round so
that's the discrete time unit that we
are looking at so here is there is an
assumption of a synchronous clock okay
everybody is synchronous intact but the
delays in the network are not in terms
of rounds meaning they are in terms of
rounds but they are gone they are not
corresponding to Unitron yes good
question
so we assume that the pis have private
that means then afterwards you have to
stop inspecting and then a crack but the
player section note the word around
writes the players Tonys know what's
wrong near him crack so they don't need
that they are not synchronized in the
round so you could but that would be
that would be a weaker model than this
so here you're allowing the corrupt
corruption to change over time if need
be but yes you could fix all the
dishonest players at the beginning then
but here you're allowing the adversary
the luxury of deciding some other
players to become corrupt because we
stopped in the middle so in this example
for right now so okay so the player
decides to corrupt then maybe it has to
release some other player and make it
uncorrupt if you want to so in this
situation if you if the player is
allowed in this example the player is
given two parties so you can drink the
photo for you model
universally the player has already
provided his or her ten ports now we are
saying that players uncorrupt what we do
what do we do about his or her previous
inputs are we in covered so okay so here
you will be a look later maybe we are
modeling this as we have a total of end
players in the system okay so when when
I mean and uncorrupt uncorrupted a new
player on corrupting a player that means
in order for the system to have the
required number of corrupt and uncorrupt
layers the adversary has to allow the
addition of a new on corrupt player so
this means so imagine a system in which
the number of players the the set of
players playing could change over time
right so if if a corrupt player is being
included in the system then and the
number of and you have a certain bound
in the number of curve players then the
adversary has the the system for our
bounds to hold needs to allow the
addition often uncorrupt player into the
system it's not the notion it's not
there is no notion of exactly
yes
so the inputs are basically the messages
that are being that are going to be
formed in the blocks yeah for newly
joined
okay so the there was this aspect of
identifying how to connect the blocks
together using hashes and then there is
the aspect of determining whether a
block is valid so for this we use a
pretty standard the random Oracle model
but it's an assumption so here the
random Oracle provides two functions a
hash and a verification in any round
every so this is exactly one of the
features of the what by this notion of
around in each round every node has
access to one call to the hash function
okay one call to the hash function but
an unlimited number of calls to the
verification function so the
verification function just to verify
whether and the same thing applies for
the adversary with a relaxation the
adversary controls some number of
players so the advice we can make that
many calls to the hash function and if
need be the adversary can make those
calls sequentially
but the adversity can make an onion any
number of verification calls just like
anything okay so you have a queue here
stands for how many how many corrupt
players that the adversary control that
many hash functions and then you have
the verification so the underlying
assumption here is that okay the best
way to mine a block is to hash and check
so in every round you make a call to the
hash and you check and with certain
probability you will succeed we will
talk about the probability shortly but
you can verify blocks without having to
use their
yeah questions about
okay so here are sort of a high-level
picture of what's going on the adversary
has dynamic control of who to corrupt oh
crap it has a full view of all on it
states it can make certain number of
sequential queries depending upon how
many how many players Ted corrupts at
every round to the hash it can read to
the random Oracle it can reorder receive
the finest blocks it can delay received
upon it blocks and I will talk a little
bit about it just now up to some amount
we follow a model that should be called
the norm lockstep synchrony in a paper
we actually refer to as partial
synchrony but we have been pointed out
that's not the right term so non
lockstep synchrony so basically what's
going on here is that within
we assume that there is a network delay
of Delta rounds which means that within
a delta period honest blocks need to be
delivered to each of the things mined by
the honest players need to be delivered
to each of the honest players so the way
when when a node that think of that has
a new node yes so the adversity cannot
doesn't have control over that
there is no notion of like a clock
how can you count rounds counting that's
the that is so there is a there is no
notion of clock within the context of a
note but there is a notion of a clock
with a baby are analyzing this time is
organized into what number of rounds and
we are stipulating that the adversary
has to deliver blocks to honest players
within queries function in a round can
you just make us my desk Akkadian which
is done you know the round has finished
honest player so the honest player can
make one query in each round can only
make one query so if he tries to so it
imagine that you're making sequential
queries it takes one round for the
answer to come back one round
consistently for everyone has passed so
I can use these synchronize now you
could if you want to devise a protocol
like that yes yeah why don't you if you
have a little delay and say that the
system is synchronous delivered by the
end of the round end you don't change
the number of players you just say it's
100 just that I can corrupt
another node it doesn't corrupt now we
have a sad occasion notion based on
public
photography's so this doesn't make sense
to us that he's attached to make sense
of this but this finale did I kill the
life struggles with the same problems
and then solve it by saying new members
and stuff like this okay so the one one
reason is we are actually going to look
at how Delta relates to just that you
have the time this is design the
particle in around the way but this is
another issue
so you take the rough Street
okay the point it doesn't really matter
what the model is like the model allows
a lot of extra features but the protocol
doesn't use them so it's analyzing it
protocol it doesn't do all these things
so so you're not making the right so the
point is that the model is not being
designed to develop a protocol the model
is being designed to analyze a given we
are not going to you're not going to try
to synchronize using this model or any
other app but we're just going to look
at the underlying protocol and actually
a bunch of different protocols and
trying to see whether we can analyze
within the context of this model so the
so don't bring the smallest unit of time
there is the network delay bound there
is so one thing I should emphasize here
once again is that the adversary can
that hold any adversarial blocks for any
length of time those are not required to
be delivered but okay so these are the
parameters we are going to okay the
network delay bound the difficulty of
mining given by this probability P and
actually we will capture it by the
parameter C which is a common way to do
it this is the mining hardness is
expressed under the parameter C roughly
the expected number of network delays
before some block is mined every
distraction of parties and the fraction
of honest parties so row and one - okay
so blockchain consistency so what we are
interested in is the notion of
consistency and there are the notion of
consistency that we follow is due to
past seaman inqilab which is also
equivalent to the Garrick yes Leonardo's
common prefix property so the idea is
simply the following that for any we
basically want to honest players to have
consistent chains and but at any point
of time they may have different views so
the way it is they share a common prefix
alternatively the way it's stated is for
any two rounds are less than our prime
and you have any two players I and J I
is honesty R at time RJ is honest at
time R prime the chains of I and J agree
on all but the last T records
okay so up until this point this fully
agrees after this you don't know sir tea
is some some bound that we will also try
to analyze okay so what I'm going to
show you just to the as an example of
what kind of analysis we are trying to
get so here is trying to capture oh what
adversity fractioned can the protocol so
in particular the Nakamoto protocol
withstand for a given block time in
terms of okay so recall the mining
hardness is given by this probability so
the only book of pass 'cimmanon shalad
gave these two bounds so this is the
consistency bound by this consistency
bond this basically is the lower bound
that means probably if you have let's
say this value of C then probably with
high probability that with high
probability you can withstand almost a
half adversary instruction regardless of
the kind of attacks you can imagine on
the other hand if you focus on a
particular kind of attack which is has
been analyzed often what's called the
delay attack you can withstand a higher
fraction of the adversary against that
particular
so that with our analysis that I'm going
to try to introduce okay so let me say
before that so just to put this in
context for example for Bitcoin 60 the
value of C is 60 because that's
basically the block and that's the
that's how the mining hardness is set in
terms of the C value in terms of the
network delay so at this level we
basically see that it is it can
withstand roughly almost of 50% on the
other hand if you look at other block
chains notably aetherium and some of the
other block chains that have pretty low
values of C they are operating in a
regime where there are at least if you
look at this particular picture there
are virtually no guarantees
if you change the okay oh the value of
the tea the value of teeth are you
saying no I don't think that should have
an impact on that because the
consistency is for some value of team
and but this is just a bound if you can
get a better bound than this but but the
the the position of the plot will not
change
yes I understand you can easily get the
block time for Bitcoin Bayesian but how
do you know what Delta Davis yes so this
is we're making an assumption here yes
casting time of propagation or is it by
Delta everyone has the message in the in
this model it's a it's a deterministic
time everybody has the message this is
sort of an upper bound on the time it
can take choose independently for every
particular message is going
and you assume that the this is the
Delta parameter talk about the
communication between honest players so
the the communication is all happening
through this underlying network so Delta
is so when when player wants to inform
about a block it is imagine it is
sending to this network and then the
adversary controls how that block how
that information is going to each of the
other players at what time have the
network so the one reason we are looking
at this sort of phone this you could say
putting this condition is that we are
really looking at lower bounds on
consistency so you want to be able to
make a guarantee that regardless of
worst-case properties we can have this
thing so this does not capture perhaps a
typical scenario but it is trying to put
a lower bound in each case the lower
bond against this attack lower bond
against this against all kinds of
attacks under this model and and so on
so that's the main reason why and the
other reason is it simplifies life
2013 which measure like the 90% the
study was done by Chris and I think that
we should because if you in has a
different our can have different paths
I'm okay yeah exactly
and also the - are very close to each
other and there's a corona of devil
nodes are on up and they got their they
have a delay I mean so I'm just saying
you know but maybe does most of it math
math to do with a more realistic model
of what the attacker can do on the net
on the peer-to-peer layer okay okay so
all right so it's a this plot indicate
for these plots are correct in terms of
the numbers that are listed here whether
the numbers are correct for the
respective protocols this is debatable
but okay so so the thing that we would
like to extract is we using a more
careful analysis using similar ideas as
I had done before using a more careful
analysis we can get tighter bounds and
these are not the tightest bounds but we
can get tighter on so what I'm going to
try to do in the remaining 15% is give
you a glimpse of how these the at the
highest level we are what we are
providing is a Markov based method for
analyzing consistency I'd like to show
you that it's a very simple methodology
and the value of it is in some cases we
can get better bounds then they're known
before there will be maybe it more
tightly bound present appear this
afternoon but the value of it is that
using that framework you can really
another analyze a host of different
you can analyze the consistency of other
protocols you can analyze family of
delay attacks you can also analyze some
other performance metrics you might be
interested in not consistency you might
be interested in how long does it take
like the number of blocks so how what
should you keep at the confirmation time
for a given transaction so we can get
some analysis for for that as well
so try to give you a glimpse of all of
this so start by overview of how we
approach the analysis of consistency
then I will quickly go over okay so at
high level the question is why does the
Bitcoin work the way it works again when
I say work here remember that our
analysis will be probabilistic so at a
very basic level what's going on is
there is let's assume that everybody is
consistent at this point and there's a
period when nobody succeeds this mining
and everyone has the same blockchain
with block a at the top somebody goes
ahead Bob finds a block P and broadcast
it
and Block B is transmitted over the
network to all other miners and let's
say this is the Delta period of time
- get it at various points of time and
at that point if everybody is here then
at this time if nothing else of interest
happens all miners have asleep be they
now begin mining using B esta okay
that's a good case but of course in the
middle Alice finds the Block C and
podcasts it and now Block C is being
transmitted over the network and since
as we assumed that there could be
different delays within the network some
players get to know about B while other
players get to know about C so there is
a fork right so of course it could
happen again and again
so there's extends B D X and C F X 10 C
and so on - what prevents for King ad
nauseum and this is where the
relationship between the network delay
versus mining hardness comes so
naturally the the more the harder you
make mining the less likelihood of this
happen so if you have a hit what we call
a hit going on is player and then you
have within a net Billy and the next hit
happens much later that allows you a
greater chance of consistency so this is
what we refer to as a convergence
opportunity you have a period of time
when liquid delay when nothing no block
was mined followed by a period of an
individual hit followed a single hit
followed by a period of natural delay
when no block was mine yes why not say
that depends on the probability on their
hull of the work is the recent
probability that two will succeed this
guy this guy why why Hank Nakamoto is
delayed but why hang it when you want to
analyze it you don't have to stay you
are not literal you don't have to go by
this forking it's not because okay I
don't have an immediate answer I'll take
the question offline they I think in
terms so one of the reasons we look at
convergence oppositely of course this
this is a this is a concept that was
given by past eminent Shalit as well as
Gary called it differently but the the
point about this identifying such what I
call a combinatorial object in this
sequence is that this guarantees if this
exists this guarantees that that the
chains are consistent now you could
adopt that instead of talking about
delays instead of talking about this
Delta you could try to come up with a
different definition and perhaps that
would be
okay so Delta rounds where no one minds
everyone hears about all blocks one
player mines a block under the Delta
rounds where no one Minds everyone
agrees the block that was mined was the
end of the longest chain now this has to
happen over honest players it's so no
honest players minds one honest player
Minds block another Delta answer so we
separate the honest players and this is
what we think of as so in order to break
consistency the adversary must break all
convergence opportunities because moment
there is a convergence opportunity
everybody is on the longest chain at
that moment so that is that is
essentially giving us the the lower
bound that we are seeking so the task
basically boils down to how do we count
the convergence efficient it is then we
will count how many blocks does the
adversary mine and then we will compare
so let's look at around our let's look
at around our plus T and during this
period there could be a bunch of
different hits separated by silent
periods of at least Delta rounds and
this gives us rise to a bunch of
convergence opportunities and for an
adversary to to kill all of those
convergence abilities the adversary has
to come up with hits
and we count the expected number of
convergence opportunities and we
compared with expected number of blocks
adversity can watch one of the
challenges in counting the convergence
opportunities is that they could be
spaced arbitrarily right so it's very
it's difficult because the spacing
between these two might be less than
Delta and so on so this is where Markov
chains proved to be a convenient way of
capturing this and because as we will
see it will it's useful enough that you
can get other interesting properties out
of it so do you take into the situation
the fact that the adversary gets a hit
outside you know the miners under the
control of the I'm sorry I was colluding
yeah even though they have a better
longer you know air the air chain they
might switch to the new chain yes yes
yes
when you in the general consistency bond
if you are looking at specific attacks
if you want to model a specific kind of
attack then then so for example one of
the attacks that people try to model as
a delay attack where we assume that the
adversary delays everybody by Delta Jana
okay so there is a specific strategy but
for the general consistency bound yes
all all kinds of okay so here is a very
simple Markov model of convergence
opportunities so there is a two states
here the first state is the what we call
the messy state this is a state where
hits are happening at a more frequent
rate than and Delta at some point that
is a delta delay at that point it moves
to state s1 and then if there is a hit
followed by a delta period then you have
identified a convenience opportunity
otherwise you've gone back to the messy
State so this simple Markov chain
captures what's going on so if you can
look at this Markov chain and identify
how much time or what fraction given up
over a period of time how much what
fraction of the time it's spending here
that gives you a bond and the
convergence opportunities so this is the
only it's a standard Markov chain the
only difference is that notice that each
of these edges has certain lengths so
this is the length this is delta rounds
this has a length which is a random
variable
similarly this has a length there is a
random variable so analyzing this is a
little bit more effort more work than
very traditional Markov chain sometimes
is referred to as a generalized Markov
chain but it's not that much more
complicated to analyze so program simply
is you define a markov model which
states and events of interest then you
compute stationary distribution for the
states and the edges and these are
standard using difference equations you
can go ahead and compute that then you
derive expectations for the events of
interest in this case we are interested
in convergence opportunity so we get a
expected number of
and then you apply concentration
theorems there are lots of well-known
journal Coptic bounds for generalized
markov chains and to argue and assuming
certain conditions hold to argue that
they are concentrated around the
expectation so this high-level framework
enables us to analyze the variety of
consistency bounds general error bounds
as well as specific attacks confirmation
times for for different protocols so to
give you an example for nakamoto
consistency we get a statement such as
this this is a bound that comes from
convergence opportunities this is a
bound that basically that's the number
of blocks that the adversary can mine as
long and as there exists Delta greater
than 0 such that this happens we get
with probability that is exponentially
small in K and T V but
so in the next two minutes let me just
quickly talk about something sort of
more things that can be done with this
model so one attack that has been often
studied is the Nakamoto delay attack
which is basically the specific attack
in which the adversary decides that they
will do a delay receive all honest box
by Delta yes sorry sorry sorry so these
are all this variable is the probability
that a certain edge is taken in the
Markov chain this is the stationary
probability lij is the length of time
expected length of time it it goes from
a certain state to another state just
compute these can be computed using
formulas such as this
this can be computed looking at the
Markov chain you can get closed form
formulas for all of these and you just
plug in those numbers in there yeah I
didn't describe that so so by there is
the stationary probability for every
node there is also a stationary
probability for every edge
and that's this the previous one in the
whole perimeter sir for for the low
values of C and I saw the city they're
very close because here you using this
concentration bounce marker chains which
has su must be less tied to normal China
pants right
[Music]
okay alright so I will go through I'll
just maybe I'll just stop with this so
just to give you an example of what can
be done so let's suppose you're
interested in this delay delay ataxia
state as zero which represents two
chains of equal length so the adversary
is trying to fork so you have two chains
of equal length if there is a hit then
the honest chain is ahead by one block
and if there is a convergence
opportunity then we have reached the
point where we have a successful
consistency on the other hand the
adversity could be lucky and could move
to two good lube and make a bigger and
bigger chain okay so and then for the
adversary there so the adversary could
be ahead of by mining its own private
chain so the real question is how long
so this Markov chain how long does it
take before the we reach this state
that's the question and that's like the
block confirmation time so analyzing
this chain requires more effort so part
of a given K we can actually calculate a
closed-form formula determine difference
equations that give the stationary
distribution we can actually write
generating functions whose coefficients
are relevant probabilities solve the
recurrence and then derive the tombola
I'll just show you this plot and I think
and presentation you can actually get
different kinds of confirmation time
length of four pounds for different
adversaries so I'm out of time so I will
go on to just leave this leave this
slide like here indicating that we can
do something and we are hoping to do
more
[Applause]
timebut
so now I'm supposed to mine the next
block